le philosophe et académicien alain
finkielkraut était invité hier par une
association d'étudiants de sciences po
et une autre association qui s'appelle
sciences po en lutte institut clément
méric du nom de ce jeune homme qui avait
été tué vous avez par des par des
skinheads dans une bagarre a voulu
empêcher la venue du philosophe hier
soir pour eux il ne faut pas laisser
parler un homme profondément
réactionnaire dont les propos
ouvertement racistes et sexistes sont
aussi dangereux qu'à tolérable on vous a
juste réservé cet extrait parce que le
communiqué fait trois pages dans le
sabir habituel de ces groupuscules alain
finkielkraut ne s'est pas démonté la
direction de sciences po non plus
d'ailleurs il faut lui rendre hommage à
la pop toujours fait preuve de la même
fermeté dans le passé mais enfin cette
fois ci elle a laissé la réunion se
tenir plus activement l'a fait en sorte
qu'elles se tiennent et finkielkraut a
répondu à la sortie de la conférence le
fascisme c'est vous en s'adressant à ses
à ces jeunes gens qui voulaient
l'empêcher de parler l'antisémitisme
c'est vous les autodafés c'est vous les
années 30 c'est vous ils sont très
exactement ce qu'ils prétendent dénoncer
claire chartier sais c'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya ce genre
d'initiative c'est inquiétant est
surtout une quelques routes qui commence
à être habitué ça avait commencé à être
nuit debout il s'était fait éjecter de
des places de la plage ils sont bien
donc il est vraiment la cible de ces de
ces groupes là je pense qu'on assiste à
une dérive qui effectivement très
problématique qui ça je dois dire alors
on pensait que dans les idéologies qui
avait été vraiment très structurante le
dire à l'université dans les années 70
on pensait qu'on avait tourné la page
que c'était un peu terminée et puis nous
revoilà avec en effet des groupes qui
militent pour la reconnaissance des
minorités sexuelles des minorités
raciales enfin toutes ces communautés
qui sont à mon sens assez inspiré quand
même des universités américaines où ce
mouvement fait rage et on arrive à des
situations totalement aberrante où là
bas aux états unis par exemple sur les
campus des associations noires qui
demande à être dans des campus réservé
pour être dans des lieux sûrs pour ne
pas être agressés on a même une
prolifération de ce qu'on appelle
les trieurs warning c'est à dire les
alertes déclencheur on vous dit avant la
projection d'un film avant je sais pas à
quoi une conférence
attention certains publics peuvent être
choqués par donc et certains doivent
s'excuser platement parce qu'il aurait
pu avoir l'attention de ce qui est
problématique c'est que ces groupes pose
de vraies questions
en effet je veux dire ya des problèmes
de discrimination qui existe pour le
cadre des féministes par exemple
effectivement il peut y avoir une double
discrimination du fait d'être une femme
et du fait d'être noir ou du fait des
tombes musulmanes c'est évident sauf que
l'un ils sont en train de camper chez
les autres de débattre tout simplement
on ne peut pas exposer les arguments
c'est exactement ce que vient de montrer
l'événement d'hier c'est à dire que
c'est du fascisme perdre mais le
problème c'est que c'est pas simplement
les débarrasser que il entend dicter le
contenu des enseignements donc mais bien
sûr non mais c'est beaucoup plus grave
que cela parce que en plus bon le
problème c'est que parmi les professeurs
on a des personnalités qui sont
véritablement acquise à toutes ces
idéologies ce soit des indigéniste les
problèmes se multiplient
justement effectivement toutes les
associations lgbt qui obtiennent et
qu'ils ont mais véritablement des
professeurs qui sont les émissaires de
toutes ces idéologies donc bon je crois
qu'il va falloir véritablement se
pencher sur cette question et le
ministère ne doit plus pouvoir fermer
les yeux parce que actuellement la
direction des universités est confiée
remise à ces groupes à ces minorités
tyrannique qui exercent leur tyrannie en
toute impunité
donc on l'a vu avec la pièce récemment
la pièce dit le fils qui a été privée
d'une présentation à la sorbonne
parce que il y avait des comédiens qui
étaient maquillés de noir est donc en
fait c'est pas bien maintenant alors ça
s'appelle la cfius parce que donc ça
singes les noirs alors qu'en fait alors
c'est fou parce qu'on en arrive à a
finalement constitué d et comment dire
bannir et interdire alors qu'il n'a même
pas d'intention évidemment d'abord c'est
faux en fait il paraît que c'est dieu il
était juste maquiller
aucun lien avec les noix et donc on en
arrive sais pas comment dire a interdit
alors qu'à aucune intention dire que la
loi l albanie elle décrit le délit de
racisme
lorsqu'il ya une intention de
discriminer l'agent n'a absolument pas
donc ça va très loin il ya une véritable
dérive que ça vous de voir que vous êtes
professeur des universités ce que vous
la voyez cette théorie sciences po mais
refait ce ratio est ce que vous la voyez
7,7
cette évolution un peu inquiétant tout
cette dérive oui moi je roule que je la
vois c'est que je la vois oui surtout
que moi je donne cours essentiellement
en anglais ne le répétez pas au figaro
et et bouger beaucoup d'étudiants qui
viennent des campus peut-être plus
encore des canadiens que étasunien qui
sont des règlements là dedans et je vais
encore plus loin que ce qu'a dit
bérénice en effet il n'ya pas que des
associations
il ya des enseignants il ya une
politique d'intimidation ça qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est à dire que l'on
cherche à peser non seulement sur le
débat mais sur le contenu des cours sur
les promotions des enseignants sur les
publications des enseignants et dieu
sait alors heureusement à sciences po
dans ce domaine on est encore préservée
j'espère prouver longtemps mais dans de
très nombreuses universités
la chose se répand et là j'ai aussi nous
à dire il s'agit pas de minorité qui
aurait trop de droits comme peu d'autres
questions le disait ces gens là ne sont
pas ne représente pas du tout les
minorités moi j'ai des élèves qui
viennent de toutes les minorités
moi même je suis une minorité vous avez
des gens qui sont oui absolument
je vous avais des gens qui veulent
imposer un agenda totalité encore une
fois appelons les choses par leur nom
il s'agit donc de 2,20 tolérance de gens
qui ont une idéologie totalitaire ça n'a
rien à voir avec le droit des minorités
donc c'est pas du tout il faut
complètement sortir de ce vocabulaire
seule essence de l'occident donc c'est
une véritable entreprise entier
occidental pour le moins au moins une
entreprise contre l'esprit contre
l'histoire contre la culture au delà
c'est à dire ses dunes
moi qui suis historien c'est vraiment à
teyran du pronostic
en histoire ils n'ont aucune
connaissance de l'histoire universelle
aucune connaissance de l'afrique par
exemple aucune connaissance de l'
esclavage aucune connaissance des
colonisations et ces gens gagnent et le
vrai problème c'est vous savez je sais
plus qui disait ça qu'ils disaient
c'était le problème du mal dans le monde
sait pas ce qu'ils commettent le bal
c'est ce qui le laisse faire et c'est ça
qui se produit actuellement sur twitter
on est globalement assez d'accord avec
tout ce que vous venez de dire
il est scandaleux inadmissible du nicole
que dans nos écoles ou fact et
groupuscules puisse vouloir interdire ce
qui leur déplaisent cette histoire est
du même tonneau ajoutèrent 34 que
l'occupation de la fac de droit de
montpellier
les sanctions administratives délirante
oui ça c'était pour dédé avait une halle
des interventions pour libérer entre
guillemets la faculté et jg de paris de
pau cette question intéressante
l'université était encore le lieu de
l'intelligence j'ai ce match moi je
pense que ce qui se passe autour d'eux
alain finkielkraut est absolument
scandaleux inacceptable et je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de penser que ça n'a pas
ça n'est pas sans lien avec qui alain
finkielkraut le fait qu'ils soient juifs
absolument absolument parce que on a le
droit de ne pas y évidemment de ne pas
être d'accord avec ses idées je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ses idées actuelles
j'ai pu l'être il y a longtemps on a le
droit même alors qu'aujourd'hui on a
même le droit même de sa triste et
parfois de ses errements de ses
obsessions migratoires tout ça oui oui
non non bien sûr mais je n'ai pas dit ça
d'ailleurs mais ont évidemment mais met
à ses idées à ses arguments il faut
imposer des idées et des arguments en
aucun cas la violence
en aucun cas et là on est face à un
problème qui prend de l'ampleur
c'est le refus de la contreverse c'est
le refus du débat contradictoire c'est
le refus tout simplement qu'on puisse
vivre dans des sociétés où tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord et donc substitué au
débat d'idées la censure la violence
le blocage non ça c'est absolument
inacceptable ce sera une très belle
conclusion merci beaucoup aussi smadja
merci à tous les trois autres
intervenants d'avoir été sur le plateau
de point de vue ce soir demain vous
retrouverai ma consoeur marie-amélie
nova bonsoir
[Musique]